est-ce que vous avez vu shining susanna
oui le film d'amour en arrive à ça mais
aussi via robert d'anvers d'un film
d'amour gêné et qu'est ce que cette
affaire sa fille maman
avis aux amoureux la ferme ostalapia est
une bonne adresse pour eux pour rompre
on y répond quoi est temps qu'une chose
du 2 mai que ça vous fait accéder à tous
les arts n'est jamais dans la peur
elle espère d'ici là tempère bon jour
sous j'ai bien vu différemment
tu change tout dans le resto quand même
que tu referme des cases de temps en
temps
je tente rsa la tête par dick cheney a
pornic a lancé la corée ça et je me
disais aussi vous n'êtes pas dû le payer
cher
vous êtes tous je passe ténu à skype est
dangereusement je me dis que c'est
peut-être quelque chose à mina avant
tout matuidi est pas laisser tomber mais
attend est évident
[Musique]
je fais encore eu beau inscrire si tu as
décidé ça comme cela bah ouais ouais tu
as pété pour
pas
les menus ou à 12h04 finish
je suis dans la force de l'âge je suis
là et bien sûr mais alors laissez
personne vous dire le contraire
[Musique]